little bit under the weather and how do
you feel physically right now among us
same as yesterday
and uh do you feel like you just played
poorly today or do you feel like you got
really good play from jordan against you
yeah he played
he played okay but i mean
he just gave me a great position out of
the opening in the second game um
admittedly he fought well after that
especially after i went b4 which was
insane i should just a castle
so he found this g5 idea which is
which was nice at least practically
speaking and then
then also there's knight f4 idea and
after that it was not was not clear
but and then yeah i guess in the last
two games he he played uh
very reasonably um
i mean the fourth game was an opening
disaster to be fair i mean i
[Music]
played a little bit too quickly and then
i realized after e5 i can just pretty
much give up winning again
i mean obviously the second game ends up
being deciding today but
is it more frustrating or less
frustrating that the deciding game is
an oversight of a bishop
i mean
it doesn't doesn't really matter that
much but
uh
yeah usually usually when i i lose these
matches it's
pretty avoidable um so that's but yeah i
don't know don't know how even to
to to explain explain that i generally
know how the pieces move but
with some notable exceptions
thank you for actually taking the time
on this and good luck tomorrow thank you